hey guys Peter Brown here with another
gamespot news update today EA is talking
about Star Wars games hold on a second
it's not that bad Electronic Arts CEO
Andrew Wilson has said in a new
interview that the challenge of working
on a beloved star wars IP is making sure
you retain the spirit of the series to
that end the publisher is looking to
emulate the approach warner brothers
took with this batman arkham games
Wilson said what Warner Brothers did
with Batman was take the core roots of
that IP and manifest that inside the
walls of Gotham City they delivered an
interactive experience that had real
ties to what you would see in the films
and what you would read in the comics
while having a life of its own because
it could provide such deep and more
immersive storylines when we look at the
Star Wars properties that's how we're
looking at it wilson also reiterated
that EA is not interested in making a
Star Wars game that replicates the story
of any films in the series well it's
great to hear that EA is taking the
spirit of Star Wars seriously let's just
hope it's focusing on the spirit of the
good Star Wars come on EA you're our
only hope anyway for more star wars in
da news stay tuned to gamespot com